dear colleagues can I ask for your
attention
let us remember the open and Global
approach that has always been the
European way we need to bring back
growth and focus on European
competitiveness
had an ambitious road map on our EU
rules on migration and Asylum and this
is what we are working on right now and
in Parliament we expect the leaders to
commit to completing the migration and
Asylum pact with us before the next
elections because Europe has what it
takes if we act together I'll give the
floor to open the debate for the council
the minister for EU Affairs Jessica
Roswell Jessica and the floor
thank you madam chair honorable members
Madam president
of the commission commissioners
on February 9th leaders will convene for
a special meeting in the European
Council focusing on Ukraine the economic
agenda and migration the meeting will
start with the usual exchange of the
president with the president of the
European Parliament
leaders will discuss the situation in
Ukraine assembling less than a week
after the EU Ukraine Summit on February
3rd
they will discuss the latest
developments on the ground and take
stock of the EU support to Ukraine and
its people
leaders are also expected to consider
further ways to increase pressures of
Russia and to touch upon the important
issues of accountability and upon frozen
assets
the 24th of February two weeks after the
special European Council will Mark the
tragic anniversity of this of the start
of the Russian war
the European Council is expected to
reaffirm the eu's Resolute determination
to support Ukraine and the Ukrainian
people for for as long as it takes
I know the parliament is steadfast in
its support Ukraine and I would like to
thank you all for this
regarding the economic agenda leaders
will discuss how EU can tackle challenge
in facing European Europe's economic
industrial and technological base in the
short term in doing so they will build
on today's contribution by the
commission on a green deal industrial
plan
among other things leaders are expected
to discuss possible temporary
adjustments on state aid policy and how
to streamline procedures while
preserving the Integrity of the single
Market
by the time of the meeting we will
probably have a deeper understanding of
the challenges for the European industry
as the commission is expected to prepare
the analysis analysis
but it is necessary to look at other
policy tools too much can be achieved by
improving the business environment and
by cutting red tape
we also need a fully developed and
integrated European Capital Market and
and an ambitious robust and sustainable
trade agenda
in the long term it is crucial for the
EU to realize the full potential of this
single Market as it celebrates 30 years
at the most European Council leaders
will discuss competitiveness and
increase productivity in the longer term
this is essential for EU to remain an
attractive place to invest for our
prosperity and for the role our role on
the world stage
migration will be another paid major
Topic at this meeting leaders are
expected to discuss ways in which the EU
can intensify its joint actions such as
strengthening control of the eu's
external borders including through
frontex support from member states
actions and the use of it tools
working with countries of the region and
Transit along all routes on Partnerships
to avoid further death encounter illegal
migration
and also issues of return and
re-admission alignment with the esa the
EU Visa policy and the fight against
trafficking and smuggling as well as the
unacceptable use of migration for
political purposes
finally calling up finally calling up
the coal legislators to continue work on
the migration pact as foreseen in the
joint roadmap on Migrate migration and
Asylum thank you very much for your
attention I'm looking forward to hearing
your views
thank you very much Minister Roswell and
now give the flaws of the president of
the position
to take the floor
thank you very much Madam president the
Alberta but a minister honorable members
last year frontex reported 330
000 irregular border crossings
this is a 64 percent increase compared
to the year before
and the highest figure since 2016.
in parallel
there were 924
000 Asylum applications across the
European Union
there are without any doubt increasing
pressures at our external borders
and it is our duty
to make sure that Europe continues to be
a space for protection for those who
need it
however the Asylum or reception system
across member states are under
considerable strength and fact is
that the majority of those who apply for
Asylum are not in Need for protection
but return rates
are at a low of 22 percent
and there is an increasing number of
secondary movement
honorable members
migration
is a European challenge
which must be met with a European
response
this might sound like common sense
but it took us almost 10 years to
acknowledge this reality
at the European Council next week I will
propose to the heads of state and
government two separate work strands
the legislative process is one and the
operational actions we can take already
now is the second
on the legislative process
the best response we can give to is to
advance the new pact on migration and
Asylum
since the commission presented its
proposals we've seen quite some good
progress we have agreed on the EU blue
card to attract highly skilled Personnel
we have established a new EU Asylum
agency in December a political agreement
was reached on three important
legislative proposals
trilogue started to upgrade our
biometric database the Euro deck
try logs to start soon on screening
so we must keep up the good pace
and here the role of this house is key
I'm glad that on your initiative Madam
presidential Roberta Parliament and
Council agreed on a road map
to conclude all the legislative work
before March next year and you can count
on the full support of the commission to
achieve that I know that vice president
Margarita skinas and commissioner
Johansson are working tirelessly on that
the second work strand is immediate
action
this is what the European Council will
focus on
over time we have developed a migration
and Border management toolbox we have
stronger agencies and we are better
coordinated
we have proven to be able to respond to
certain demands if we work together
take the instrumentalization of migrants
by Belarus
all of a sudden rise of irregular
migration in the western Balkans
or our response to Russia's brutal
aggression against Ukraine a whole
continent has mobilized for our
Ukrainian friends volunteers rushed to
the borders families opened their homes
and not only their homes but also their
hearts and at the institutional level we
immediately activated temporary
protection for ukrainians
we know
that we can address increasing
challenges if we take action together
and now we can do this again
here I want to outline Four Points of
action where we can make a real
difference on the ground
the first is
we have a shared interest in strong
external borders
the most pressing issue right now are at
the land border between Bulgaria and
turkey
we can strengthen the border with
management capabilities
we can also provide infrastructure and
equipment like drones and radar and
other means of surveillance
we've done last year for example in the
last years for example in Romania we've
done it in Spain and Greece and in
Poland
and we can increase the presence of
frontex
on the other hand
we must urgently address the situation
in the central Mediterranean
the migratory pressure has increased
significantly
and all too often tragically at the
expense of human life
we need to support our member states as
well as our North African partners
in coordinating their search and rescue
capacities
and we will continue supporting unhcr
and iom on the ground to help build
capacities for Asylum reception and
return
at the same time we will continue
supporting member states
to address challenges along the western
and Eastern Mediterranean roads
honorable members
behind all this
they are criminal Networks
they are organizing ruthlessly
the Chevy life vests the boats they're
robbing the migrants they're trading in
human life
we have to intensify our fight against
those Smugglers
and we will launch a new anti-smuggling
partnership with key third countries
this will bring together prosecutors and
law enforcement authorities supported by
europol and supported by Euro just
together we have to stop this business
of exploitation
my second point
is focusing on faster and dignified
returns
every year there are around three
hundred thousand thousand return
decisions taken by member states
but only around 70 000 people are
actually returned
we have to get better
some of the shortcomings we can act on
now
for instance a return decision
that is taken in one member state
should be valid in all member states
so if a person with a return decision by
Italy is found in France
that person can be directly returned to
its country of origin
this will become possible now with the
Schengen information system
that enters into Force into operation in
March and we want member states to make
use of this possibility
thirdly
we have to address secondary movements
while ensuring effective solidarity
solidarity and responsibility are two
sides of the same coin
and therefore these two issues can only
be addressed together let me give you
some figures
and some elements that are important for
us we must work together to reduce the
incentives for secondary movements it is
very good that we have the doubling
roadmap now since December in place but
member states of course need to
implement it now
and at the same time if we look at the
voluntary solidary mechanism agreed Last
Summer
this should not only be on paper
it needs to deliver
until today
there are only 8 000 pledges for
relocation
and just round about 400 have actually
been transferred
so European solidarity must and can be
stronger than that
and we will need to see to this with a
permanent solidarity mechanism in the
new pact on migration and Asylum
last but definitely not least
there is the external dimension
we need to engage more closely with key
partners
migration management must be built in as
one important aspect of the European
Union's relations with partners
overall our relations need to reflect a
strategic engagement in a spirit of
cooperation
we should recognize the interests of our
partners and cooperate with them
by supporting education by creating new
businesses business opportunities by
fostering job creation
that same Spirit of cooperation
should help us to reduce irregular
departures and step up returns
Talent Partnerships Visa policy trade
and investment play an important role
here
as well as opportunities for safe and
legal Pathways as part of our overall
comprehensive approach to migration
management it is a fair balance that we
need to find
honorable members migration is very
complex it's a matter of understanding
each other's challenges and a matter of
working together
this is what we will present to the
European Council on the 9th of February
on the completely different sheet of
paper
let me ask you for your kind
understanding
that I have to leave the plenary right
now because I am together with the
College of commissioner now on my way on
a mission to Ukraine where we want to go
together as a college of commissioner
thank you very much
[Applause]